pour le plaisir on vous a compilé tous
les maux qui sont à propres qui sont
propres à tpm pc un petit peu le lexique
de tmp regard dsk une bonne d'arc à ce
soir barca non moi je pense qu'il est
dark alors à quoi ça y est j'ai été en
place comme au far sartec vous avez tous
eu moins gras sera dimanche soir normal
quoi skins est arrivé était bien peignés
du ca à steinbach bull a sera de race
rappelle comment ça va bien
la baisse c'est vrai que là tu es
maintenant je vous jure que j'entends
des dégâts des fois par l'univers et
tout dans des restaurants il avait tué
je veux une offre j'ai appris que vous
aviez déposé le mode arcade à l'inpi
c'est ça oui pour faire quoi
bahia pas devenu pour offir banon mais
on sait jamais une version c'est la
grande la grande d'arc à la grande race
mais vous ne voulez pas me sentir
déboires songez pas déposer votre nom